un autre sujet qui me hante est là il ya
3,5 millions de personnes dans le sud
est de la france qui sont privés de
télévision
on y revient ouais ils ont par contre
ils ont tf1 tmc tf1 et nrj 12
oui c'est à dire que m à son côté j'ai
dit je vais très forte fx tmc est bon
donc ce groupe tf1 et je vais tuer
michel bon certes y'a que lundi soir où
ça marche quant à jean marc morandini
le reste du temps peut pas dire que ce
soit où fiona et nrj 12 pour masquer
d'histoire donc un complot complot c'est
vrai qu'il ya 3,5 dans la personne qui
peuvent pas regarder c'est une expliquer
aux téléspectateurs ce qui s'est passé
en fait l'information qui avait un
incendie sur un site qui relaie les
antennes de télévision qui à 3.5
millions de français qui n'ont pas
regardé la télé et là on voit qu'il ya
sur le total télé star le nom de télé
ses serviteurs au total qui regardent la
télé il ya cinq millions de français en
moins hier soir et donc il ya une
information qui est passée inaperçue
parce que la vraie info c'est qu'il ya
des chaînes qui sont accessibles et donc
d'autres qui ne sont pas accessibles
exactement celle qui sont accessibles
c'est tf1 la chaîne parlementaire public
sénat tfx nrj12 et tmc et toutes les
autres chaînes on peut pas les regarder
donc ça a des conséquences sur les
audiences et moi je trouve ça horrible
m'ont déjà pour les chaînes pour les
audiences non mais c'est vrai uniquement
parce que fossard que les chaînes
vendent des pubs en se calant sur les
audiences
donc comment ils vont faire non mais
c'est quoi l'enjeu va falloir que
médiamétrie
profitons des ravins avons réajusté lors
des prochains jours ils n'ont pas payé
ça chez nous mais ils vont essayer de
réajuster voix lors des prochains jours
parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya un
problème de 4 millions de
téléspectateurs
c'est donc à brienon de téléspectateurs
c'est ce que phantom duléry il en fait 5
passes et c'est dangereux parce que
c'est les vidéosurveillances ont vu
c'est un con
ando c'est un acte criminel les gens ont
voulu détruire justement la 5g et on a
de plus en plus en europe
du côté britannique il ya quand même des
techniciens qui ont été agressés il ya
d'autres incendies il ya des acteurs
j'ai un petit peu partout sous prétexte
qu'il ya un médecin américain qui a dit
justement que la 5g allait être
dangereuses pour la santé et que même le
virus était dû à cause de la 5g
on a tellement été relayée sur les
réseaux sociaux par millions et par
millions que maintenant il ya des
commandos de partout qui font des
incendies aborder les bornes répondent à
un sujet la rue un regard des rois bien
depuis hier matin une importante panne
prive une partie du sud est de la france
de téléphone de radio et de télévision
une panne qui touche 3 5 millions de
français et qui serait due à un incendie
criminel
trois millions et demi de personnes
privées de télévision n'y a plus de
doute en il s'agit très clairement d'un
incendie criminel un cas partiellement
détruit la nuit dernière
l'un des plus puissants émetteurs de
télévision c'est un incendie qui a
touché le site de télédiffusion de
france se trouvant à quelques kilomètres
de marseille un émetteur ultra puissant
qu'il second plus important de france si
à l'heure actuelle les autorités ne
connaissent pas les auteurs de cette
attaque
des rumeurs insistantes parle d'un
groupe de militants opposés au
déploiement de la 5g en france des
groupes qui ont annoncé d'autres actions
dans les jours à venir une situation qui
inquiète
si certains déplorent les dégradations
qui ont eu lieu et souhaite que les
coupables soient sanctionnés
tant que c'est attenter à la liberté de
chacun que de les empêcher d'accéder aux
médias et faut pas casser ce qu'est
casse ils font les impressionner
d'autres regrettent que ces actions
puissent pénaliser certaines personnes
qui ont l'habitude de regarder la télé
je pense à toutes les personnes qui sont
seules elles n'ont que la télé hi et
pour elle ce serait dramatique
aujourd'hui difficile de connaître les
conséquences de telles actions mais le
pire est à craindre
alors y aura-t-il encore la télé à noël
c est un mec c'est incroyable ça a c'est
vrai qu'il ya plein de gens qui disent
oui moi je suis tout seul regard la
mairie dit comment je vais faire et je
trouve ça incroyable on se pose la
question si aura encore la télé à noël
je comprends pas avec tous les canaux de
diffusion avec internet avec les
plateformes avec les boks comment ils
n'arrivent pas à réparer ça en moins de
24 heures là tout le monde est pénalisé
en fait c'est même pas ça allait aller
au plus simple il y en a combien des
trucs de télédiffusion comme ça en
france le gros truc comme ça il y en a
combien il avait un prêt de
marseille-fos oui grosso merdo après
solaire d'oyonnax blues est d'à peu près
2 alors regardez regardez comme il y en
a mais aujourd'hui on sait qu'il ya des
mecs dans la surveillance des vigiles
des maîtres chiens qu'on pas de boulot
tu prend 1,10 m chien pour surveiller un
site et ses réflexes ou les chercher
internet et des machins des mêmes points
10 mètres et des chiens mais non mais tu
arrives tu fais si tu mets les sites de
surveillance est important la télé c'est
la formation certes je suis neutre qui
tue mais ça sous télésurveillance n'est
pas de médiamétrie me dira m et n'a rien
à voir là dedans tu prends dix chiens
dits malinois dit mec tu verras qui va
se passer ici voilà merci 30 millions
d'amis